ciao a tutti tornati oggi nuova
challenger super popolare in america lo
slang telepatico però noi e mi occuparlo
con tante realtà le stacca forse potete
vedere stiamo già separati da un muro
bimbi io non vedrò quello che pesca
vitale vitale non vedrà quello che pesco
io adesso ci stiamo guardando nec emilio
della camera però dopo abbiamo aggirarlo
vediamo niente funziona in pratica
faremo quattro round per ogni round una
volta a testa
dovremo cercare di connetterci
mentalmente e cercare di pescare la
stessa saca porsche con gli stessi
ingredienti dentro ogni volta che uno di
noi indovina prendi un punto quindi alla
fine vedremo chi ha fatto più punti e
soprattutto dobbiamo cercare di fare lo
stesso identico non vedendo questo
mercato l'altro quindi sicuro uscirà
perfetto uguale a cercare di capire i
gusti dell'altro quindi cercare di
indovinare cosa sceglierebbe l'altra
persona quindi vediamo chi vincerà
questa volta prete che cosa un'altra
gialle
le fatica consegnateci pure che tipo di
cialente volete che facciamo e lasciate
un bella questo video vediamo se
riusciamo a raggiungere i 10 mila light
mettetevi comodi patatine poco
fate il tifo o per me o per vitale e
vediamo un po come andrà questa
challenge voi potrete vedere per tutto
il tempo e abbiamo scelto la susseguente
nono e solo alla fine vedremo che misura
si è dato prendi ha subito e abbiamo
girato lo schermo quindi ora non ho idea
di appoggio alle novità ore potrebbe
anche star mi facendo dei segni delle
boccacce ma io non ne ho idea
anzi a cento sulla spesa naturali dello
scudo
bene bene piace la batteria scarica
vediamo se renzi si connette che
batteria
la batteria da balla a chi inizia per il
primo round chi segna dobbiamo scendere
non siano no1 delle serie la sede
connette a ok allora ok il primo round
come scelta abbiamo la sacca fosse
marmorizzata con viola e blu oppure la
stacca coach bianca e rosa
allora io ora serve una di queste
dimmiquando a scelta
ora cerco di inviarti il segnale stai
ricevendo insegnare tornando da allora i
poteri situate secondo me è giusto e non
te lo posso dire alla fine scopriremo
che possiamo iniziare ora iniziamo a
versare il primo ingrediente sperando
che l'altra persona sarà quello giusto
perché abbiamo un pesantissimo
non posso dire niente però è bellissimo
anzi
vedremo poi a dire troppo strano sentire
la sua voce ma non vederti robert i
costi anche michael separati è bravo
lei allora tocca a te
quindi prossimo round andiamo di non di
decorazioni ma di un ingrediente
aggiuntivo allora forse con la barba o
la lozione no esatto o la schiuma da
barba o lascia un po quindi io devo
scegliere una delle due prima video
inviare il segnale lei senta sto ancora
decidendo attento e non dire niente
io devo pensarci
no che sì penso non lo so cui scegliere
tutto sono io che dove illuminare tu non
ne voglio fare uno slang bello ma lei
non sarà proprio scegliere io perché ora
tocca a te insegne ok ok il dio del
segnale
nostro inviato noi non diciamo niente
stimolante l atm gps su ok
ho scelto che vediamo che sia lo stesso
pronti
lei sa che abbiamo sbagliato allora ho
sentito un rumore dove vetta è stato il
rumore sospetto
vedremo non si stato del 7 qualcos'altro
che sta facendo questo cuore c'è stato
un rumore sospetto
[Musica]
sembravo a sentire i miei rivedremo qui
tu che non sei il primo quelle che
abbiamo scelto da un certo un quadro
nota ma possiamo di girarlo si no
vedremo anche qualità è il bello ok è
pronta bona allora la serata la prossima
scelta dobbiamo scegliere fra palline o
molto nei presidi web
strade di città hanno permesso aspettano
ancora inviate insegnare che aveva tema
di fuori pronte a recepire recepisco ok
ho scelto è scelto il segnale che hai
ricevuto sport è chiaro si creasse
silvia di nuovo la derivate strigliare
si come no a si pensa di aver capito
uguale ai 70 cerco che andiamo ad
offrire
[Musica]
io mi piace bene mi piace molto ma
basterà la prossima scelta allora è già
un ultima scelta
il nuovo mi stavo divertendo tanto
allora tocca mezzo stop se abbiamo le
fishbowl blu che poi abbiamo le
conchiglie blu lascia dunque il gf
céleste devono gli artigiani
leggiamo nei con dei piccoli dei piccoli
puntini privati e ok io ho fatto la mia
scelta già di già classica come è stata
pubblicata perché perché una scelta
basata su l'esperienza e su quali temi e
tranquillità brabus allora io segnale
manna però mangiano più forte questa
volta è ok e trascorsa
[Musica]
bisogna diventare interamente la mente a
quella sacca forse è il nome di quello
stesso volto dello stesso destro sempre
state indirettamente intensamente
ok fatto si chiama
[Musica]
hai fatto no io mischia ok misti anch'io
siamo telepatici lo scopriremo rapporto
abbiamo la prova che cosa sto pensando a
mangiare bravo troppo bene e io lo sto
pensando venissero vibrava com'era
andiamo ad attivarlo una volta che è
completamente attivo attiviamo lo
attiviamo vinto ci vediamo al cellulare
prima la finiamo e poi una volta che
completamente attivo lo guardiamo lo
togliamo il super è così ma casomai
dando il suo addio era da un pò
sbilancia beh siamo toccati cosa che
distruggendo il cavolo la vedo male
economia mi pesta sicuramente che è
successo
stiamo bene già dai suoni penso che
riuscirò a capire che cosa e mezzo beh
un po si capisce dai suoni che
ingredienti e mezzo che decorazioni come
sentito solo mettendo la soluzione
veramente no dopo interattivo voi sapete
già
beh l'abbiamo fatto simile uguale o
completamente diversa sapete già chi ha
fatto che punti ma noi non sappiamo
niente da un altro punto e o non
sappiamo ancora qual è quello più bello
di vita è in quanto a bellezza questa
mentalità pietro come brevetto in qua se
mio bene
perché a volte quella mariano
qua
la frittata facendo ancora solito
vediamo accadere tutto
forse ci siamo quasi purtroppo
appiccicosi ma certi che sarà più bello
del mio onestamente si tenessero lei è
qui ma la cosa mi ha detto vengo sempre
ma non fa questi suoni portale questo è
perché quella non ho fatto pochi a
facebook intendiamo oddio pagare tutto
ma ero nel posto pochi e troppo noto la
signora mentre mia
che volgeva tempo king digitale sta
migliorando secondo voi 11 dopo 11
allora il momento della rivelazione è un
tronti che così è brutto lavoro tutto
guidato siamo pronti dai pirati letto
qui aperto wow
[Musica]
bello no dai
questo è un male ma questo mica siamo
stati bravissimi
allora stiamo veramente che le parti si
sarà più uguale telepatia 103 108 che
hanno fatto il resto
viola si la prima o poi da barbarello e
shampoo però ho sentito che per noi una
soluzione si chiama fuori pericolo
[Musica]
lunghezza nonché scoppiettanti perdendo
studi pallone quindi e poi hai messo le
palline allineavo l'utensile rookie ne
lei ne abbiamo fatto stress che ne
incriminate tutte e due in svizzera il
quale più bello anche se sono
praticamente uguali preme la schiuma da
barba è lo shampoo ed io mi immagino che
vuoi mettere sentivo mentre bene mattia
de sac à poche rinnovate diponibili
cifra giusta è quella giusta
se gli avessi se avessi certo la schiuma
da barba perché ha un po vedi dovevi
connetterti mesi perché mancano i
giallorossi forse la stiamo a parlare
un'aperta continua guidonia che flight
burning paduletto però vi aspetto sono i
dentisti non me l'aspettavo davvero che
fossimo più ricchi credito rinnovati sì
che bella fa battista presso potete
vedere
giustamente reparto qualcos'altro
scrivete sicure nei commenti che ciò
nelle scuole che facciamo assieme e ora
vi lasciamo bamba altro castellini e su
cui cliccare per vedere le nostre altre
challenge i nostri video divertenti live
cliccando su quella che preferite e
buona visione
ciao ciao